les cherry on voudrait parler de la
couverture la coupe du jour c'est la
grosse date ce week-end la couverture du
magazine oops donc vous verrez la noaa
et laeticia hallyday
c'est vrai ensemble et ne va se plaindre
elle est une vraie couvertes alors je
vous le dis c'est une vraie couverture
la plus grosse barca c'est que les mecs
se sont pris la tête voilà et je trouve
ça assez d'art car moi je l'aurais dit
d'ailleurs quitté marca mine de rien
parce que c'est vrai que le photoshop
est très fort puisque je vous le dis je
n'ai jamais croisé laetitia aline et de
ma vie mais quand je vous dis dans ma
vie et de ma vie je n'ai jamais vu et
bien fait ou pas alors regardez reste
quand même un petit peu calcaire garder
quand ils ont des toits et voiliers ou
pas voilà ça regardez ils m'ont
découvert est en fait plus que prévu
voyez ou pas voilà donc vous voyez c'est
ça
j'aime beaucoup à vous montrer regardez
boudreau à quel point ces des phénomènes
sur deux photos différentes et m'ont
collé la même tête
regardez mais sauf que l'éthicien elle a
changé de tête royal moi j'ai toujours
[Rires]
suis toujours en rattrapant elle vous
appelle justement quand tim mais ils
m'ont quand même permis d'apprendre
quelque chose c'est que je suis content
sioniste regardez je sais même pas qui
avait une soupe est extraordinaire
regardez ma maman mais non fournie quoi
à mon avis je suis dans incroyable
talent l'année prochaine je veux faire
là ça
c'est un truc de ouf je pense vraiment
je vous le dis ils ont cru vraiment que
j'avais fait incroyable talent et
j'aimerais quand même qu'on prenne le
temps de regarder les légendes qui sont
sur les jantes sont extraordinaires et
ma préférée c'est la première regarder
la première légende
je le fais pour johnny il était fan de
tpm paix mais je les adore y en a eu
d'autres
il ya des doutes regardez regardez les
autres donc bon mon bahari d'accord mon
babaorum voilà donc elle rigole à mes
blagues
donc là je suis assez content et assez
content regarde et écoute voilà écoute
ma petite beauté si tu viens sur le
plateau ce sera la barca du siècle voilà
ce que j'aime dans l'article c'est qu'il
ya des passages magique j'apprends comme
angers séduit laëtitia avait l'année
ils ont dit qu'elle avait eu un coup de
foudre pour moi ouais on m'a fait
plaisir
mais pourquoi il faut ça mais c'est quoi
voiture iseli l'attaqué ou pas
franchement c'est tellement drôle d eux
je vous le dis c'est une couverture un
peu parodie qu'on fait quand même une
l'âge ou parodier innovant neutre et
marron mais moi mais moi je l'achetais
ses mensonges et une fois dans votre vie
par laeticia je n'ai jamais croisé de
manille parce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
partie de l'histoire qui est vrai et ce
à ses fantasmes
ouais fantasme encore dire la panacée
non merci c'est votre l'égérie voilà
donc est donc ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a été faire un petit
micro-trottoir avec cette couverture
pour savoir ce qu'en pensait de ce
couple laeticia hallyday et moi même
regardez
[Musique]
ils sont ensemble ça passe ce soir moi
je pense qu'ils vont très bien ensemble
ils vont ensemble
ah oui on cent pour cent pour cent
est ce que vous en pensez celle là c'est
grave ça mais je m'en doutais non non ça
durera pas mais après tout chacun sa
live moi ça me fait mal pour port joli
mais bon
sinon moi j'en croise un pin à pin que
je vois ça surtout pour johnny
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'est une chose je n'ai jamais
rencontré lady cela et en plus jamais
vraiment j'aime tellement johnny que
vraiment je ne pourrai jamais voilà même
mais regardez les réactions
les gens vont savoir dit que c'était une
connerie